Yan, you're up.
>> Hey, how you doing? Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, your connection good.
>> Yeah, I can hear you perfectly.
>> Okay, so people understand
you reached out to me, but tell them a
little about background. Obviously, you
had converted to Islam, right?
>> Yeah. So, I grew up a Christian. My dad
was a minister and my brother's a min
minister and I just went through some
really hard times and I got really angry
and bitter. So, I left Christianity and
kind of did my own thing. Uh tried uh
Messianic Judaism for a little bit. That
didn't work out. So, I was on EF Dawa's
live with uh Issa Dawa and I took my
shahada and I got really really deep
into it for a long time and was given da
gave people shahada.
>> EFA
is dawa.
>> Isa.
>> Yeah.
>> I never heard of him. All right. So you
then took shahad alive. Then what
happened?
>> So I got really really deep into it. Uh
thinking I would have peace. Uh you know
uh I was going through a divorce at the
time and uh the more I got into it, the
more depressed I got. So about three
years into it, uh I'm laying on my bed
and I'm crying. Um, I tried to unalive
myself
>> and um, there was a Bible under my bed
that I just threw under there and I
opened it up and it says, "For God is
near the brokenhearted and crushed in
spirit."
>> Amen.
>> So then I was like, there must be things
they're not telling me about Islam. Uh,
because I started to feel really unsafe
about it, about salvation, because I
heard, and I don't know if it's true,
that all Muslims go to hell. And I was
like, well, I don't want to go to hell.
So um I kind of did research over other
stuff that I was uncomfortable with that
I don't know if if it's an authentic
hadith uh because you know I was
learning Arabic I can still recite Quran
and stuff like that. So uh I just had
some questions about some hadith about
uh one the age of uh I know she was nine
about preubescent
>> and then uh if all Muslims go to hell
>> before you move on it's uncontested no
one disputed Aisha's age until modern
times it's uncontested there are even
Muslims responding to the so-called
evidence that she was older showing it's
a lie so it's uncontested but
nonetheless what else did you want to
know because you said about the Trinity
as well.
>> Yeah, just uh Old Testament sources
because I know whenever I was given Dao,
we would always run to the Old Testament
and uh stuff like that. So, is the
Trinity in the Old Testament? And uh my
final question is I I'm feeling some
guilt for giving shahadas and I find
myself because I did it so much just
randomly saying throughout the day like
sallallahu alaihi wasallam or uh just
quoting um quoting Quranic verses
without even thinking I'm doing it and I
have to catch myself.
>> It's become instinctive. It's been
instilled in you and it's become second
nature. But you need a cleansing. You
need a purging. But that means you got
to go to church. You got to get confess
and you need the Lord Jesus to cleanse
you of your demonic infestation because
you've been demonized. Islam demonizes
you.
>> And I I'll also want to publicly uh
denounce Islam. I haven't done that
quite yet.
>> I'll have I'll let you do that in a
minute. But let me just go through the
verses for the people that Psalm 34:18.
Yahweh is near to the brokenhearted
[clears throat] and saves those who are
crushed in spirit. Psalm 51:17, "The
sacrifices of God are a broken spirit, a
broken and a contrite heart, oh God,
you'll not despise."
Contrite means humbled heart. Isaiah
57:15, "For thus says the one high and
lifted up, who dwells forever, whose
name is holy, I dwell on a high and holy
place, and also with the crushed, the
one who's oppressed and lowly of spirit
in order to revive the spirit of the
lowly, the one oppressed and crushed, to
revive the heart of the crushed." So,
this is what he's referring to. He's
referring to Psalm 34:18, but I gave you
a few more. And then our the promise of
our Lord. I just want to give them the
verses that you were alluding to.
Matthew 11:28-30. But I will give you
advice. [clears throat]
I'm going to give you some advice, okay?
Before I go into the scriptures. Matthew
11:28:30. Come to me all you who are
weary and heavy laden, and I will give
you rest. Salam. [clears throat]
Take my yoke upon you and learn from me,
for I am jump gentle and humble in
heart, and you will find rest for your
souls.
Seems like it's breaking you, brother.
In Jesus name. [snorts]
Amen, brother. Weep. Weep to the Lord
Jesus. He's alive. Muhammad is dead. And
you'll find rest for your souls. For my
yoke is easy and my burden is light. For
my yoke is easy and my burdens light.
This is the promise of Christ. But I'm
going to give you some advice. Okay. Let
me tell you what I've heard from what
you said.
>> Yeah.
>> We're all broken. We've all been through
hellish childhood like me. And from what
I heard you say, your emotions
are very strong and your emotions get
the best of you. And this is going to be
dangerous if you don't ask the spirit to
empower you to reign in your emotions.
Why do I say that? Here you go. Proverbs
28:26. He who trusts in his own heart is
a fool. He who trusts in his own heart
is a fool, but he who walks wisely will
escape. Proverbs 3:5-6, "Trust in Yahweh
with all your heart. Subject your
thoughts, your feelings to God's will,
not how you're feeling. Do not lean on
your own understanding. In all your ways
acknowledge him, and he'll make your
path straight." So my point being,
you're very emotional and you go by
emotion. And this is why you won't be
able to last in anything because if
you're not feeling that sensation, that
sensation dies out. you lose interest
and find something to give you a
temporary fix. That's why people get
addicted to drugs. You're going to have
to learn it's not about how you feel.
And you're going to have to learn your
emotions are unstable. And you can't act
impulsively. You're going to have to
train yourself to do what is right. No
matter how you feel and trust God when
he tells you this is right, even if you
don't feel it, otherwise you're going to
destroy your life.
>> Are you with me there? Oh yeah. I I read
something similar to that uh the other
day in my Bible. I just can't remember
where it was about your heart leading
you into deception and stuff like that.
>> 179 says the heart is so [snorts] you
have to train yourself not to go how you
feel because listen the way to salvation
and even Muslims will tell you this but
because a lot of the truths of
Christianity
have been stolen plagiarized butchered
in Islam. Islam. Whenever it's true,
it's because it's agreeing with the
Bible. Okay? Christ himself said
following him is going to be painful.
You're going to have tribulation. You're
going to have trials. It's carrying the
cross and denying yourself. The cross is
painful. And he says, "In this world,
you will have tribulation." He didn't
lie. He said, "You will have trials, but
if you cling to me, trust me,
>> I have overcome the world."
>> I read that, too. That's crazy.
>> As confirmation. And he says, "I will
give you my peace." Islam has no salam.
It's my peace I will give you.
>> But my point being,
the Lord told you, you can't trust how
you feel.
>> Trust me to guide you and ask me to the
strength to reign in your emotions
because your emotions will deceive you
and make you do things you're going to
regret later. Train yourself, brother. I
don't want you to because notice what
you told me. You went try to find peace.
Messianic Judaism didn't work. Islam
didn't work. Well, the pattern will be
even if you come back to Christianity,
you're going to jump from one
denomination to another if you're not
feeling it. That's not how you arrive at
truth and that's not how
you [clears throat] show your
faithfulness to God.
>> Yeah.
>> You see, it's I'm not feeling it. Well,
it's not about feeling, man. Because
let's say you return to Christianity,
but you go to denomination. I'm not
feeling it. you're gonna jump to another
denomination and then another
denomination because you're going by how
you feel.
>> Yeah. Well, I actually um I wanted to
clarify I did accept Jesus. I just
haven't been public. Uh there's a lot of
uh fear I'm feeling about it because I I
made a lot of friends in Islam who
helped me whenever I was struggling with
some things. So, uh I I have a lot of
fear uh in coming out, you know,
publicly.
>> Yeah, I know. You even said that you you
were you worked with Central Da.
>> Yeah, Central Dawa. Me and him gave Dao
together, whatever. He first started out
even before he knew Arabic. I was kind
of helping him uh you know bring people
to Islam and stuff. And then once I left
because a few people found out I left
and I ended up coming back uh I was I
left and didn't really follow anything.
Uh he completely just stopped talking to
me. So I haven't even heard from him.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I just saw a clip recently where
he said he's done with Da.
Someone sent that to me. Let me let me
play it. He's done with Da. Uh I got to
be careful. I don't want to give away
the identity of the person. Let me see
if I can download it.
>> And my old videos are still on uh Tik
Tok, I believe, of me giving DA and
stuff.
>> So, they are try to delete them. Here we
go. This was sent to me. But here, I
want you to see this. Here it is. He's
done with D. This was sent to me. Hold
on. Let's see this if I can play it.
Where's the volume?
Where is the volume? I can't I can't
hear the volume.
No volume here, dude. Shoot, man. All
right, let me see if I can play this
somehow.
But it's not working because it should
have Let me see. He just came out saying
he's done with the Dallas scene. He's
tired of it. He thinks it's garbage.
Why doesn't it give me option of uh
All right, let me find out if I can play
it. Hold on. Let me see if I can play
it. No, I can't do this because I don't
>> Yeah, but I don't want to give away the
identity. I know I have it, but I don't
want to give away the identity of the
person who sent me.
>> And also, it's funny how when had two
lives in this month calling them out
>> and they did not show up.
>> You believe that?
>> But the one time where is by himself, he
wants to show up.
Listen, bro. I got I got out of the
debate scene for a reason. Um
I'm going to take the the da out of my
name. I want nothing to do with it
because of what it's becoming.
>> Hear that?
>> And
>> oh wow.
>> Want to say it's it's genuinely
disgusting on both end.
>> Okay.
>> From both sides.
>> Both sides. I'm going let it play again.
>> And the Christian side.
[clears throat]
>> That's it.
>> Okay. Yeah,
>> appreciate you coming up.
>> Okay, one more time. Listen that I'm
going to show you the video that I'm not
lying, but I don't want to show it
because on my
files, you can't hear the sound, but
listen to what he said again. Listen.
>> And also, Central, it's funny how when
two lives this month calling them out
and they did not show up. Can you
believe that? But the one time where she
is by himself, he wants to show up.
Listen, bro. I got I got out of the
debate scene for a reason. Um,
I'm going to take the the dawa out of my
name. I want nothing to do with it
because of what it's becoming.
And I'll be the first one to say it's
it's genuinely
disgusting on both them,
from both sides, the Muslim and the
Christian side.
>> Yeah, I agree. [clears throat]
That's it.
>> He says, "Okay." Now, just to show you
that I'm not lying that it's him here. I
can show, but I can't get the volume.
See, this is him. You see here, there's
no name, right? Okay. All right. I don't
want to go away in the identity person.
Here it is. See, this is what I was
playing.
>> Oh, wow. Yeah.
>> This is what I was playing. But for some
reason, I can't play the volume here. So
I had to
Oh, this is someone who's doing this.
Oh, okay. That was Yeah. So right there.
So right there.
I may upload it to my channel. Okay. So
he's done. And I agree with him. The
scene it's become ridiculous. But
nonetheless,
nonetheless, he's he's done with it. But
coming back to you now, brother. You
want mental stability.
You want to trust God with your
emotions, not subject
your decisions based on your emotions,
right?
>> Of course. show.